hello everyone welcome today's live
broadcast invisible influence
I'm Robert Castellanos of lab ruse and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars contributing to the advancement
of science through content sharing
capabilities lab roots is a powerful
advocate in amplifying global networks
and communities for more information
please visit lab roots comm we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge a slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problems through the green
Chuen a button lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing educational credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and followed the
process of obtaining your credits I
would like to now introduce today's
speaker dr. Jack Gilbert professor Jack
Gilbert earned his PhD from the
University UK and
2002 and received his postdoctoral
training at Queen's University Canada he
is then returned to the UK in 2005 to
Plymouth marine laboratory as a senior
scientist until his move to Argonne
National Laboratory and the University
of Chicago in 2010 currently professor
Gilbert is director of the microbiome
Center and professor of surgery at the
University of Chicago he has authored
more than 200 peer-reviewed publications
and book chapters on metagenomics and
approaches to ecosystem ecology finally
he's a founder editor-in-chief of M
systems journal I will now turn it over
to dr. Gilbert for his presentation
okay I hope everybody can hear me and a
great honor to be here I apologize for
all the state I look like I'm in bed
I've actually am but not actually a
better just in the spare room of my
house however um it's my great honor to
be able to present to you all I'm gonna
be talking today about how microbiome in
individuals and people can affect
outcomes in our in our patients and more
specifically how we are using the
microbiome in order to understand the
way in which the body responds to
treatment and how we can understand
these specific implications of lifestyle
of immune variants and even of surgical
practice are formed outcomes in patients
so I'm gonna specifically also talk
about the indoor environment I do run
the microbiome Center at the University
of Chicago the Marine Biological
Laboratory at Woods Hole and the Argonne
National Laboratory this is a
multidisciplinary effort with more than
60 faculty at the 30 departments focused
in this area so start out with a lot of
little story and my I have a variant
gene variant that gives me a
predisposition toward the development of
outsiders so I have a likelihood of a
more than 25 times over normal of
developing Alzheimer's disease and I got
this from my mother she has the same
variance but she has a double mutant of
this varied which gives her a heightened
level even that doesn't mean she'll
actually develop a plans disease and
it's far more likely that the
environment in which she lives the
environment in which I live might select
for my free disposition and leave me
open to a more specific disease
phenotype so the reason for this is and
one of the key areas environmental
interaction is the human microbiome it's
the the some 30 to 50 trillion bacterial
cells present in and around your body
around 1.3 times the number
bacterial cells in your body who are
human that tend to one ratio that people
being banned about it's actually a
back-of-the-envelope calculation error
but this this microbiome that we we find
in our body actually comes from the
environment and is shaped by how we
interact with the environment through
our diet our lifestyle and various other
phenotypes and so what we are interested
in doing is understanding how the
microbiome could be playing a role in
developing our predisposition and
developing the actual development of
specific conditions we get our
microbiome predominately from our mother
in the initial phases we see this with a
with a rapid inoculation through vaginal
delivery of vaginal microbiome so here
we have for example the in a it's a PCA
plot you can see each dots is a
microbiome sample representing the
relative abundance at some thousand
species and each dot and what we're
seeing is that samples that come from
the models regina versus the babies that
were born by venom delivery have a more
similar microbiome those red and pink
dots and closer together whereas
children that have borne by a c-section
their microbiome is much more similar to
models skin so that a developer
microbiome that's more akin to the skin
environment which they first interact
with you can see the mother's mouth of
the top there in yellow it's very
different from both of these
environments so this is the starting
culture if you will this is the
sourdough bread or the craft beer that
you would normally acquire earlier in
life and we think this is incredibly
important children born by c-section of
a heightened risk of developing a tepee
so allergies asthma those kind of things
skin conditions and they also have a
high risk of developing obesity and
diabetes as well as some neurological
conditions many of these conditions have
been likened or linked or associated
with changes in the microbiome and
therefore it's not too much of a leap of
faith
to understand that disrupting this early
phase of microbial development ie from a
predominately vaginal microbiome start
to a dominantly skin microbiome start
could have a impact upon the
developmental trajectory of a child
predisposing them to some conditions
again it doesn't necessarily mean they
will get those conditions many children
are born by a c-section and go on to
live totally normal healthy lives but
there's an increased probability of a
potential threat to their long term
chronic health the fact that we get in
after we born we interact with the
environment is obviously axiomatic this
leads to a unique microbial community
all of us have a unique microbiome in
fact I can identify each one of you in
the audience or myself or my family
based on the microbiome signature and I
could out use that in clinical you know
I could use that in criminal
investigations not just clinical
investigations for criminal one's some
work we're doing currently with the
National Institute of justice which
points in this direction might bring
that up later but even identical twins
have a unique microbiome and they
obviously acquire the same microbiome
from their mothers at birth but then as
they grow up one may be mixed by a dog
and the other one may be you know likes
to play in the dirt a bit more and those
microbial exposures shape the types of
bacteria that they acquire now whether
the microbiome they acquire shapes their
community by directly allowing organisms
to colonize their body or whether the
experiences they have with the world
shape their immune system which in in in
you know directly shapes the microbiome
through selective acquisition retention
and killing we don't know we think it's
a bit of both so we're working on the
premise right now that increased
microbial exposure with the environment
is incredibly important lots of other in
a minute we do know that we are
currently eroding our microbiome leading
to a
reduction in the diversity in our in our
Western world and also a reduction in
the types of bacteria that we find on
our bodies when this is led to a
significant increase or a surge in our
attempt to understand how the microbiome
environmental exposure may play a role
in certain conditions there are company
299 or 399 sort of ongoing clinical
trials many of those using a treatment
called people microbiome transplant or
we take a microbiome of a healthy person
and Transplant it into a an unhealthy
person in order to improve their
gastrointestinal health and we can see
that the microbiome is now being
implicated in many individual conditions
and we're also finding that many
individual treatments like for example
artificial sweeteners
or even situations like antibacterial
soaps
triclosan etc can have an effect on the
microbiome in fact we just wrote a tour
of science on this and then one week
later the FDA banned it after exploring
for 40 years so I'm not saying that our
tutorial is directly linked to the FDA's
decision but you know you can ever hope
to have the microbiome influenced well
these are three nuggets we like to tell
in our community run work we've done
with apartment defense has identified
that microbiome alters the skin
chemistry through metabolizing sweat
from metabolizing oils to produce
aromatic hydrocarbon aromatic carbons
are that influence the the
attractiveness of an individual site on
the body to mosquitoes mosquitoes scents
you in the area by honing in on your
carbon dioxide cloud but then when they
get down to the body they decide which
sites of bites by actually honing in on
the unique series of hydrocarbons
aromatic carbons that are being released
from the site so there are some
mosquitoes that are private fredrik
biting wrists and there are specific
class of bacteria living on my wrist
the metabolize swears in a specific
'we releasing certain types of from
aromatics whereas the bacteria on my
ankle are very different when they
release other types of aromatics and
different types of mosquitoes are more
attracted to that site being able to
disrupt that signal and could lead to a
significant reduction in the
transmission of diseases formed by
biting insects tylenol is only toxic to
your liver if you have certain types of
microbes in your gut there's a microbial
interaction between the chemicals in
tylenol and metabolism products which
leads to a interaction in the liver
causing a toxicity so we could
theoretically screen people's stool to
look for certain types of bacteria which
would predispose someone to being to
having a heightened risk of liver
toxicity due to a 30-minute burn
treatment we also know there's a picture
of two flies humping which is a strange
thing to have in any slide but in this
instance we know that fruit flies can
change their behavior for having their
microbiome altered in fact I can take
the microbiome one fruit fly transfer
into the gut of another fruit fly and
then alter the fruit fly that the first
fruit fly
Francie's to the secondary flat was a
strange tongue twister but the general
principle is that the microbiome in the
first fruit fly is actually affecting
its mate prefects and and therefore by
transferring it into the second proof
fly I can alter that fruit fly to make
reference to the other the first fruit
fly so I can change the sexual behavior
of an animal by altering the bacteria
present in its body you know you might
think that the sexual behavior an animal
is always predicated by its genome that
this food not to be the case so we're
very interested in getting the
microbiome into your medical records and
in fact there's no clinical evidence to
suggest that the microbiome and
microbial therapies could be extremely
important the most widely cited of these
is the use of curing seeded of where the
people microbiome transplant here we can
see typical vancomycin no vancomycin
with a lavage treatment for seeded as
around a 30 percent success rate for
people with
chronic infection not responding to
treatment where is an infusion of donor
feces a people microbiome transplant can
lead up to a 94% recovery rate in this
groundbreaking study the study was
actually counseled early because it was
viewed as being so successful it would
have been unethical to continue to treat
a controlled population so what do we
think about the microbiome and how do we
see it as being important well you've
gone from living outdoors with rich
microbial exposure it's a living indoors
with a very limited microbial exposure
which we've eradicated because we use
antibiotics that kill the good bacteria
along with the bad ones as well as that
trick lizanne we think this is reducing
the microbial diversity of our bodies so
we're leaving ourselves open to
development of allergies atopy and
various other things we painted by
actually increasing the microbial
diversity or adding certain very
specific types of bacteria back into our
body we may be able to protect our
children and adults from from some of
the allergens which are leading to some
of the chronic illnesses you see in the
Western world today you know in a paper
from the New England Journal of Medicine
that we published two or three weeks ago
now we demonstrated that dust from the
farm such as an Amish farm can have a
protective effect upon the bacteria
found sorry a particular effect upon
certain my strains that are predisposed
towards development of asthma and so
that by taking the dust and there
bacteria and allowing these these mice
to experience that dust we can protect
them from developing asthma now this is
in contrast to the dust from a home of a
Hutterite which is a different type of
logistic where the children in that farm
and the are not allowed on the farm
because the farm is a very mechanical
very different environment than that of
an Amish farm now while the Hutterites
live a very similar home life to the
Amish they don't live a very similar
farm life when we think this reduces the
types of bacteria that the enter into
the home environment
you've got the where the Amish have
around 1% aspirin their population the
Hutterites had more than 25 to 30
percent asthma in their population so
there's a big disparate gap between
people living in continuous contact with
the animals and people who are disrupted
from the animal interaction remember the
Amish children are playing in the farm
all the time the home is on a farm
whereas the house where children don't
ever get near the farm we also know that
you can alter the microbiome of the mass
and affect its ability to be sensitive
to particular allergens so in this in
this peanut allergy study up here the
peanut specific IgE response you can see
that a specific pathogen free mouse
standard mouse model has a very low
response to the peanut specific IgE to
the entirety of the allergen calling a
no response of the IgE up taking its
serum whereas a germ-free animal the gf
and the red column has a significantly
elevated degree of response to the
peanut allergy causing a order of
magnitude higher increase in response in
the variable if weary conventional eyes
as germ-free mice that response goes
away they're no longer responding to the
allergen if we add just add in this
iniciative formas we actually don't see
the protective effect this type of
bacteria doesn't offer a protection to a
germ-free animal if we take every animal
and we just added Clostridium organisms
particularly costs trivial cluster 14a
we see a significant reduction in the
response of the animal to a peanut
allergy so those costs trivial organisms
are protective against the peanut
allergy and recently we've identified a
bacterial probiotic formulation with
colleagues over in Italy just a
lactobacillus rhamnosus GG that when
given to children very early in life
under the age of three months can
protect them from developing a milk
allergen response of cow's milk allergy
and you know works around 50% of the
time so we are now also looking at ways
of altering that formulation in order to
try and improve this
well you know that microphone can also
affect depression bacteria in the gut
produce neurotransmitters as well as
influencing the immune and endocrine
system which can alter neurotransmitter
activity in the brain the production and
consumption neurotransmitters by
bacteria in the gut
obviously alters the balance of new
transmitters in the serum which can
affect neurological activity across the
body and we have seen many instances and
there's more work coming out where we
can alter the neurological depression
phenotype of an animal by affecting its
microbiome in one of the most elegant
studies you say at the beginning
low-hanging fruit study we take a
specific pathogen free a typical not
germ-free Mouse typical Mouse with lots
of bacteria in it we can see that the
back the mouse will hide inside the
boxes in elevated maze this is just a
plus maze across about a meter off the
ground and the standard activity of a
mouse standard behavior would be to hide
in that box and stay hidden what we are
interested in doing is looking at what
happens when the we take the bacteria
away from that Mouse so when you make
this mouse germ-free it loses all that
fear lose all that anxiety no longer
hides inside the box it walks along the
platform and explores its world as if it
doesn't have a care in the world
in in the natural world that Mouse would
be eaten because it wouldn't stay hidden
and you might think that this response
to stay hidden would be a genetic
predetermine --nt nothing to do with a
microbiome and that may be true but the
microbiome is shaping that response so
where is the the mouse that was brave
and ran around got eaten bacterial
interaction with the immune system and
within brain the nervous system appears
to affect the behavior of this animal in
such a way as to lead to a a improvement
of that phenotype so it stays with
inside the hidden environment take all
those bacteria away the mouse goes crazy
so we need to understand that in order
to be able to understand depression
explicitly also know that bacteria can
cause obesity
one of my colleagues was morbidly at
least 385 pounds lost 130
pounds by eating in traditional Chinese
whole-grain diets over about a nine
month period and over that nine month
period he lost a lot of weight obviously
but he also lost a bacterium
Enterobacter colossi b-29 and when he
cultured up that bacterium and added it
back to mice the mice put on a
significant amount of weight so in this
instance we have a bacterium that can a
single species which can induce a
phenotype in the germ-free animal and
that animal is eating the same amount of
food as the other animal but we think
this bacterium is helping that animal to
process that food more efficiently and
make more energy available to the host
and also terminator it can also disrupt
the the hormonal system and and liver
functionality and disrupt circadian
rhythms which can lead to an increase in
fat deposition due to a stress response
so where do we get our microbiome from
we get our microbiome mostly from the
environment we find ourselves in MC
ranking you are a a child I'll move on
to another slide earlier imagine you're
a child growing up in in an environment
where for example you were exposed
continuously to the Amish farm you're
going to be exposed to ducks and pigs
and chickens and and horses and cows and
etc and their microbiomes are going to
mingle with yours to a certain extent or
at least in influence your immune system
to develop in an appropriate
constructive way but if you bring a
child from the bar from the c-section
delivery straight back into say an
apartment on the 31st floor of a
skyscraper in Chicago then that child is
not going to experience any of those
other stimuli it's only going to
experience really bacteria that come
from other people in that environment
because our houses our offices are
reasonably sterile we know that the
bacteria that come off of our bodies
colonize these environments there are
around 36 million bacterial cells
leaving your body every hour and they
colonize and coat everything
can they die but we need to understand
what that death or what that survival
looks like in order to be able to better
design homes and environments to make
them more health-promoting
so we've been examining this space and
looking at seeing ways of me to examine
to map from microbial interactions
between safe people and their surfaces
in their homes so in this study for
example we looked at we had four
individuals or two parents and two
children living in one home and we
tracked them daily over six weeks with
their hands their feet and their noses
and then looked at the kitchen floor the
bedroom floor and various surfaces the
hands would normally interact with in
order to be able to map how the micro to
move in between those surfaces one thing
we saw was that there was a more
significant microbial interaction
between the mother and the children
there was the father and the children
but it was also a significant
interaction between surfaces that would
normally interact together so the feet
in the floor hands and surfaces of touch
hands you can see hand one is the hand
of a young infant and that his
microbiome is significantly interacting
with the bedroom floor and to see if I
can so you can see hand one is
interacting with the bedroom floor much
more significantly on this loop here and
that that interaction is because that
was a infant crawling on the bedroom
floor and so his hand was more
significantly my probably interacting
with that space this is important if we
want to be able to track where people
interact with environments and what kind
of microbes they may be colonized by and
we see that if we add dogs into this
scenario this is a family with three
dogs that the degree of microbial
interactions increases exponentially and
dogs actors and microbial superhighway
conduits if you look moving back to here
from the outdoors into the home as well
as moving bacteria more freely between
people couples that have a dog are much
more likely to be more my currently
similar to each other than couples
without a dog because the dog increases
the degree in microbial sharing between
the couple and leads to an increase in
microbial similarity so we were very
interested in how to understand
and developed this structure but my wife
maybe get a dog on the basis of this
research his name is Captain Bo Diddley
that's a picture of him and he has
actually been increasing our microbial
diversity of our home so we have him to
thank and I talked a little bit a bit in
the beginning about how your unique
microbial fingerprint could be used for
microbial forensics so I thought I'd
take it they'll detail out of health and
just talk about this very briefly so I
need some tea so for example here I have
a what I call us a source tracker map
where I I I've got sources to the
bacteria that are found on say look at
the top right hand corner the kitchen
counter so so for example if we just
just focusing in just focusing on this
one and here we have a kitchen counter
and have three people and three dogs you
can look at the right-hand side and I'm
looking at how there might provide
contributes to this surface over time if
you look at person 1 person 1 is a young
man in age 25 living with his parents
person 2 is his father in person 3 is
his mother and then there are three dogs
if you look at the time point I've
highlighted under on the kitchen counter
under that red arrow a hundred percent
of the bacteria found on the kitchen
counter over that time period come from
the mother and in fact the majority the
bacteria nearly all time points come
from the mother for the kitchen counter
so this is obviously a very gender
imbalance environment she actually goes
away shortly after around around here
she goes away and she leaves the home
and her microbiome starts decreasing the
kitchen counter and the father's
microbiome starts to increase and this
is because he's been left to his own
devices we assume and he had to do the
cooking and therefore he might probably
interacted with the kitchen in a much
more robust way so we can use
the microbial fingerprints left behind
up people in order to be able to
understand that more effectively and one
thing is very interesting for us is that
being able to track and map this could
be used in criminal investigations and
indeed we have been able to start
exploring this the face on the right
hand side versus do with it with the
unfortunate cover of a Time magazine
article highlighting this and these
photos are from Time magazine so I
apologize for the other but in this
instance what we are dealing with is
working with the Chicago and Florida PD
- Police Department to see if we can use
the microbiome as a forensic tool so we
have mocked up break-ins around the
country when we send in our team this
the young man in the bottom right hand
corner is actually that 25 year old
young man but here his name is jerod
Hampson Marcel and he's the team leader
for this effort in our group and he goes
around the country working with local
forensic departments to see if he can
identify who broke into the house
obviously we know who broke into the
house because we we have the burglars in
our team so we we see if we can identify
in different environments and we're
building up a database of some 2000
individuals to see if we can improve the
probability that we can identify an
individual based on their microbiome
signature that was fine aside but just
point out that the the clinical research
that we're doing is also having a
significant role on other fields getting
close to finishing up here we know that
the microbiome is very important in
hospitals so we wanted to take the kind
of research that we did in homes and
flights Hospital environments this is
our new 800 million dollar Center for
care and discovery at University of
Chicago and we opened in in February
2013 but we managed to get in there in
January 2013 and explore it for around
two months prior to the opening when it
was very very clean and there were no
patients and doctors then we continue to
monitor it every day for 365 days
examining the patient's skin the patient
room samples like floor and bed rail the
air
water samples the hospital staff and the
nursing station did again did this every
day 365 days to build up a picture of
how the microbiome developed in the
hospital bear in mind we had a brand new
hospital and then to examine ways in
which to if that related to any clinical
outcomes to the patient's they're really
really looking at microbial sharing but
on a very grand scale this image shows
the floor microbiome as it went from
being unoccupied to occupied so the blue
dots that blue cluster dots on the
left-hand side are from an unoccupied
Hospital thought and then as the
hospital became occupied the doctor move
over here to the red and the occupied
hospitals are very different microbial
community I've seen the microbial
community for me occupied hospital comes
predominantly from patients and the
doctors and the nurses and the cleaning
staff who are shedding their microbiome
into those environments in fact we could
identify which patient was in which room
any given time based on a microbial
signature on the floor or on the bed
rail or even on the wall because their
microbiome was being shed into that
environment one thing to note in this
was that the infections that people
suffered the healthcare associated
infections that people suffered in that
environment we found no correlation
between the presence of that infection
in their clinical record and their
microbial interactions with the
environment so we could find no evidence
to support that that bacteria came from
the hospital
in fact in nearly all the instances and
you had quite a not a significant number
that in the tens roughly 400 patients we
analyzed over the year of those are
those 20 25 patients
none of them well they all appeared the
microbiome the bacteria that infected
them may have been present in their body
when they came into the hospital either
that or they acquired it as they walked
in the door which seems extraordinarily
unlikely and it was very different for
each one of them now
this suggests that we should start
thinking about ways of examining the
microbiome of the patient when they come
in and maybe thinking about where he's
at treating the patient when they're in
the hospital and they're just treating
the patient but for treating them
Michael
I am as well so I actually am in the
department surgery and have worked very
closely with surgeons or my colleagues
John al burdy has been a significant
driver towards on helping me to get
involved and understand the microbiome
in surgical infection so cervical
infections are obviously a major problem
we understand them to be predicated upon
the potential for surgeons or the
environment cause a bacteria to get into
a site and colonize it and cause an
infection but in many instances special
gastrointestinal surgery there's there's
no real evidence that the infective
agent actually come to the outside and
in some situations such as a
gastrointestinal surgery we're
introducing in a stenosis for example
we've reset to a piece of gutter and
we'll say a cancerous polyp region we do
two things there we actually cut open
the gut and pumping oxygen which
actually nullifies some of the bacteria
kills some lemon stresses the rest and
we pump the body full of antibiotics and
those antibiotics also affect the health
of the individual and the microbiome
then we stitch up the gap forming nasta
Matic Junction mislike a final insult
the stress the body's under starts to
cause the body to sequester nutrients
from the gut causing a nutrient depleted
environment which stresses the bacteria
even further and causes them to change
phenotype producing a colonization of
the wound site and they release enzymes
which start to break open the wound site
in order to get nutrients back and they
cause leak and in this instance a leak
anastomotic leak can be fatal
we've identified bacteria present in
animal models prior to surgery that are
that then change phenotype due to the
stress they're under and colonize that
site we think that phosphate and nitrate
stress may be among the biggest drivers
and so we've actually identified
particular chemicals that we can add
back into the experience of the patient
to help that patient to improve their
health over time so in this instance
we're actually able to significantly
advance our preposition that surgical
infection may be due to bacteria already
present in the host may be on the skin
may be in the mouth may be a need for
vaginal cavity or your genital cavity or
maybe even in the gut and that those
bacteria need to be kept for one of a
better word happy or stress-free in
order to prevent them from activating in
virulence mechanism and infecting their
host in particular way so for our
perspective it's very important to be
able to understand how how to treat from
my profile as well as treating the
patient and we are significantly
altering many of our surgical practices
in order to be able to do this so just
to finish up I just want to highlight
again our microbiome Center we are this
is a new initiative or a mind I'm an
ecologist but I'm also now working as a
professor of surgery and this is a
paradigm shift that all medical campuses
are really starting to embrace
ecology in the body is as important as
understanding most clinical concerns is
seems axiomatic to me but is a new
paradigm for many clinical care programs
so the microbiome Center actually brings
together scientists studying the
industrial application marine and
terrestrial environmental applications
agricultural applications as well as
health and animal and plant welfare in
order to be able to use all of that
transdisciplinary expertise to improve
and significantly advance or scientific
program in each of the individual areas
one case in point in this and it's an
interesting one just to make be the
research that I just showed you on
surgical microbiome actually originated
in part in understanding that bacteria
in the ocean and activates certain
mechanisms to sequester and reacquire
phosphorus from oceanic organic material
when when they enter into a phosphate
depleted environment when there's not
enough phosphate around but here in the
ocean activate mechanisms to get the
phosphate back right I'm
went into patients from when we saw that
the phosphate in the gut went down when
and said well maybe the same things
happening in patients and indeed the
same thing happens the bacteria in the
gut when the phosphate goes down because
the body is sucking it out of the gut to
repair itself and the phosphate goes
down bacterial that stress and they
activate a phosphate acquisition
strategy which is why they then colonize
the wound site to break it open degrade
it down and grab the phosphorus back so
by partnering up between seemingly
extraordinarily disparate areas were
able to significantly advance research
paradigms in areas that we normally see
the light of day thank you very much
it's a pleasure talking to you and I'm
happy to answer any questions
well thank you very much for that
amazing presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
possibly can and our first question is
dr. Gilbert is it possible that the
mental disorders our relation with
microbiome yes so yeah so the we
actually I work specifically with
depression especially perinatal and
photo natal depression in women
neurological development in infants and
children and have a very particular
interest in autism in in all of those
instances there is considerable evidence
from our animal models altering the
microbiome can play a significant role
in the development of those conditions
so for example if we if we look at
autism the work of Sarkis mazmanian and
pull the lake for Patterson out at UCLA
and laying this out has demonstrated
that the bacterial communities inside
the gut of an animal that has been
activated towards certain forces and
developmental phenotype can have the
neurological neurological symptoms of
the disease significantly suppressed by
altering the bacteria present in the gut
but by adding in a particular type of of
probiotic they can actually suppress
things like these stereotypical
behaviors that those animals demonstrate
as well as some of the anxiety behaviors
you know there's new research coming out
that shows that a microbiome transplant
from a neurologically healthy rap to a
rap demonstrating a fragile X syndrome
style autism behavior can affect its
social structural behaviors so it
becomes more socially cognizant so
there's there's a lot of evidence to
suggest there's interaction the
mechanism is still hard to pin
but as I said bacteria in the gut reduce
things like precursors and serotonin
from they produced neuromodulators like
gaba they produce acetylcholine and all
of these some of these can pass the
blood-brain barrier things like gaba
seem to activate neurological receptors
in the gut hormonal imbalances they can
they can bind up the gaba combined onto
hormone receptors and they can also
affect neurological transfer of impulses
via the vagus nerve in fact in some
studies we've taken probiotic
lactobacillus added it into a mouse
model and the mouse will show altered
gaba product productivity in the brain
just with the introduction of a
probiotic if you sever the vagal nerve
if you give the mouse of a gotta me then
the probiotic does not have any effect
upon gather activity in the brain so
there's definitely an interaction during
the gut and the brain right anyone
anyone who's ever cup happier or sated
after a meal understands this but we're
starting to understand that it could
also be playing a role in neurological
disorders and so there's a lot of work
on going to try and understand those
specific interactions
thank you very much and our next
question ISM doctor do you have any data
on microbiome during remission or
reoccurrence of primary tumors and did
the type of neurological cures alter the
microbiome okay so yes there's some very
interesting work a number of interesting
studies that should highlight on
encountering the microphone so I work
very closely with group staff at the
Mayo Clinic and various other
communities here in Chicago where we are
very interested in trying to understand
the particular types of bacteria that
could induce rapid inflammation at the
gastro intestinal wall site and and
therefore affect the development of
precancerous polyps and then heighten
the risk of developing a cancerous polyp
so from our instances we've identified
bacteria that can specifically increase
the risk of developing a cancerous polyp
and and exacerbate that it's also
compelling work coming out of our animal
models from our groups here at Chicago
that have demonstrated the potential to
improve antibody derived or driven
antigen activated cancer therapies such
as a new block a therapy for melanoma
and we think there's evidence from the
animal models that were able to
significantly improve the efficacy of
the treatment by adding certain bacteria
back into the experience the
prerequisite there is that an or the the
understanding that and mechanism is that
the bacteria activate an immune response
leading to heightened potential for the
white blood cells to reactivate and
access the the aberrant tissue so you
know by using a moon rock a therapy to
to target the cancerous tumor you're
actually able to increase the immune
Kalama tree responds with the bacteria
added into the experience of the animal
and therefore alter the pickasee of the
therapy itself so this is ongoing
research but there is definitely very
specific links between oncology and
microbio
thank you very much and doctor my
question is this a can microbiome be the
cause of cancer well in reference to the
last question
well not necessarily it's only cause it
can play a role in the development of
that as I've just highlighted the fact
that bacteria can affect inflammatory
responses which can lead to a
significant increase in the likelihood
of developing a cancer if you're
predisposed is is the paradigm
thank you and getting to this on how
long does it take for one person's
microbiome to be replaced by another's
in a defined room
that's a really good question we so if a
person is but it all depends on the on
the context if I have one room
controlled room for example and I have
one person walk into that and spend say
ten minutes actually actively doing
something in the room walking around or
lifting up objects and then I have to
leave that room and then I have another
person come into the room shortly
afterwards we would still be able to
detect their microbiome the first person
for around seven to two hours if that
person second person made in the room
sends two hours so for around three days
it's it's reasonably detectable well at
least above the above probability
frequencies but if if for example
someone broke into a room and and that
room had you know fifteen people living
in it or a house with fifteen people
living in it and there is a massive
amount of activity constantly going on
then it's not likely their microbiome
signature be eroded significantly faster
and will probably become an identifiable
as the reason the microbiome for
forensics research is not a replacement
for anything it's just a potential
addition it's another piece of trace
evidence that if applicable and if
useful at a particular contextual system
could be could be
thank you indulgence is a fine really
influenced micro biome and eventually
our health
oh yeah okay so just the PHA Joan is the
question a page ohm is related to
viruses and page specifically phrase
attack bacteria viruses attack bacteria
yeah I think the page is incredibly the
pedro pedro mix is an incredibly
exciting area we have some very
interesting data that could suggest that
phage that attack bacteria when they
become abundant a particular area could
actually be the trigger for certain
disease phenotypes even pulmonary
diseases by bacteria building up in the
lungs themselves do not activate say a
by broke by prata content or fibrosis
but the phage that then attack those
bacteria because they've got ear become
abundant fades and become abundant
because they are using the bacterias at
host those phage can activate an immune
response certain toll-like receptors
such as TR l9 can respond to those page
and once those toll-like receptors are
activated it can significantly elevate
the likelihood of localized inflammation
and then trigger fibrotic event so yes
the phage own is becoming an incredibly
important element of helping us to
understand how the microbiome is what
role the total microphone of the
bacteria the fungi the viruses in the
body and even the archaea what role
they're actually playing you actually
think that archaea are actually far more
diverse we've previously thought they're
low in abundance but they're very
diverse inside the body and so even the
archaea could be playing a significant
role in our health
you know we this is still a very very
early phase of investigation
thank you and do you foresee facial or
nasal testing of the microbiome for
patients pre-admission testing or prior
to invasive procedures in the near
future
yes absolutely so Patricia your your
very spot on for us especially we you
know we're looking at low-hanging fruit
at the moment for example or for Mary
pnuemonia if we if we look at the oral
microbiome of patients they're going to
be aspirated then we can actually see a
correlation between the types of
bacteria present in their oral cavity
and the the chance that they will get
aspirated pneumonia so we are very
interested in that particular area and
for other treatments such as even even
looking at their risk the the nasal and
oral oral and yield for communities
could be extremely important as a proxy
for determining what's going on in the
rest of the body we're not there yet we
need much bigger databases but it's
definitely going to be something that we
do free admission in the near future in
order to reduce the likelihood of
complications to entry
thank you thank you and what is the
current understanding the relationship
between microbiome analogies
so you know the basic proposition is
that the microbiome plays significant
role in regulating the atrophy or
allergic response of an individual or a
number of roots some bacteria of
pro-inflammatory and they can release
compounds which are responded by the
immune system and can lead to a
significant increase in inflammation
other organisms are anti-inflammatory or
can reduce the inflammatory process by
producing things like short chain
fatty-acids butyrate propanol eat a
steak each rate specifically as a role
to play in in recruiting t reg cells
regulatory t-cells into the epithelium
of the of the gastrointestinal tract and
those Directory T cells produced
compounds which suppress inflammation in
the rest of the immune system so the
dance or the interaction between the
bacterial community and the immune
inflammatory response we think is the
biggest driver for for our allergies in
general seasonal food or anything else
the allergic to so we are very
interested in trying to understand that
and many of the commercial therapies
that are being developed are looking at
ways of increasing the types of bacteria
inside the garden infants especially
that are able to recruit t-rex and
accumulate t-rex if regulatory t-cells
in the gastrointestinal tract so that's
the basic premise of right now
thank you our occupational diseases
enhance or limited by microbiomes for
example solvents or heavy metals or
various lung diseases
yeah that's that's a good question it's
possible you know heavy metal exposures
and solvent exposures and even say you
know coal mine dust exposures could
influence the microphone and that could
be a component of any disease phenotype
you know you might be careful about
trying to hang too much on the
microphone but you know bacterial
communities are pale fungal viral
communities inside our body they're all
part of the system right and anything
that perturbs them or anything you know
that could be the body's own response to
something for turbine or killing off
certain types of bacteria it's going to
have an effect of some kind so it's
important to be able to track that
understand it and see if we can see if
we can really start to piece together
the role that the this disturbance could
play and thank you very much and dr.
Gilbert can a two-week usually vacation
to developing countries change one's
microbiome I've noticed the one change
in my health after a trip to Thailand
where I spent a month and how long does
a person need to be exposed to a
different micro biome environment to
change their own microbiome
you know it's a very very complicated
question you you don't know the answer I
mean one of my colleagues had a paper
out at the monitor they might provide
daily for 365 days to people in the
people that went abroad the person went
abroad in that two people study their
microphone did change within days of
being in that new environment but if
only about five or eight percent of the
microbe microbial community worth was
affected the rest of it remained
relatively the same and as soon as they
returned to the US they might provide
Mouse back to its old self so that
probably diet and juice variants right
and understanding how diet or a change
in diet because of your new environment
could affect the microphone is important
the important thing is if you are abroad
and you get a traveler's diarrhea or
another disease that's going to affect
your immune system which is also going
to affect your microbiome and that could
have long-term consequences we know that
that happens in many individuals that
get those kind of diseases so traveling
abroad is going to have an effect but
the specifics of that effect are going
to be very personal independent
and how advanced is a research in
children under the age of five at the
microbiome Center and doesn't include
peanut if you mean for allergies for
food allergies there's a significant
increase in research on the of children
especially infants and toddlers and so
we are working on that right now and we
are a food allergy research and
education network hub so we all spoke
node so we are increasing the research
in that space when there are as a group
of researchers at the University who are
working very specifically in that area
and peanut allergy is one of the
conditions being examined
and one of the diseases you find
interactions with microbiome and can
they be reversed by changing the
microbiome well that's a very very big
question not when I can answer right now
as I said I listed probably some 30 or
35 different diseases that have a role
to play and as they're also said the
microbiome is part of the system so you
change the microbiome and you're going
to change some part of the system so the
interactions between there are
incredibly complex
all right and we have time for one last
question so thank you very much doctor
and it's James think that yeah I'm sorry
it is in regards to weight loss and
bacterias were related to weight loss
and how this would improve treatment on
obesity with microbiome one study that's
identified bacteria can have play a
significant role in improving disease
phenotype so very specifically those
that study looked at whether infants
children who were lean versus their
identical twin who was a beast and have
enrichment certain types of organisms
and they did and when they tricked
isolate those organisms add them to my
cipro texting right and developing
obesity so there is work on going to
look at weight loss or weight gain
prevention and in a specific field so
all right thank you very much dr.
Gilbert for your presentation and do you
have any final comments before you wrap
up just like to say you know there's a
wonderful series of questions thank you
very much
bear in mind the microbiome is not the
panacea reveal it's just something
that's been recently identified that
could play a role in helping to improve
disease and health treatments for
particular individuals so we are very
interested in exploring it in a
precision medicine capacity and trying
to use it to determine why some people
respond and other people do not respond
to treatments and or have very variable
symptoms for particular disease states
so I think there's a lot of work needs
to be done but it's an exciting time
okay thank you very much I would like to
thank the doctor once again for all of
his contributions inverse presentation
I'd also like to thank laberd's for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
December 7th you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye